[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
11 februar 1991 in italien feiert man
Karneval auch in santoca in Kalabrien
junge Männer der
familienta und pelo Romeo albern
betrunken herum und bewerfen sich mit
Eiern aus Eiern werden wenig später
Böller dann wartet der Spaß in eine
brutale Schlägerei aus hier könnte die
Geschichte als dorfprügelei enden aber
San Luca ist ein Epizentrum der
Mafia-Organisation drangeta und die
beteiligten Familien sind deren Bosse
und weil das so ist fängt hier erst eine
lange Geschichte an sie führt unter
anderem dazu dass 16 Jahre und 185 Tage
später bei BILD-Reporter Frank Schneider
mitten in der Nacht das Telefon klingelt
ich kann mich noch sehr gut daran
erinnern ich hatte damals nachts auch
wirklich immer mein Handy an 24 Stunden
und dann ging mein Handy früh morgens
und ich bin dran gegangen und hatte
einen dran heute kann man es erzählen
sozusagen verjährt der Polizeifunk
abhörte heute ist das ja nicht mehr
möglich und sagte zu mir du musst
schnell aufstehen wir haben fünf Tote in
Duisburg und mein erster Gedanke war ein
schwerer Verkehrsunfall irgendwo gegen
den Baum gefahren junge Leute nach der
Disco und sagte dann auch zu dem
Kollegen der wo sind die denn gegen
gefahren und er sagte nee in nirgendwo
gegen Gefahren die sind erschossen
worden und das werde ich nie vergessen
dieses Gefühl fünf Leute erschossen ich
habe dann auch sofort gesagt da musst du
dich verhört haben das kann nicht sein
fünf Leute erschossen und habe dann den
Hörer danach direkt wieder in die Hand
genommen nachdem ich aufgelegt habe und
den Pressesprecher der Polizei angerufen
der damals nachts auch immer für uns
erreichbar war habe den geweckt und da
dachte ich in den Menschen als der
verschlafen drangehen na ja das kann ich
stimmen weil wenn was wäre wäre ja schon
wach und in dem Moment wo auch zu mir
sagt das immer weißt du wie viel Uhr es
ist und nicht so ja ihr habt dann gebe
ich fünf Tote in Duisburg weiß ich
nichts von klingelt im Hintergrund sind
Festnetz Telefon und er sagte nur mist
ich glaube du hast recht dass die
Leitstelle legte dann auf und richtig
zwei Minuten später zurück und sagte
hast doch nicht recht sind nicht fünf
sind sechs mehrere Tote liegen vor dem
Restaurant da Bruno in der Nähe des
Duisburger Hauptbahnhofs anders als in
anderen Großstädten ist das
Bahnhofsviertel hier nicht schmuddelig
sondern gediegen hier residieren Anwälte
Ärzte und Unternehmensberater aber im
Morgengrauen des 15 August 2007 herrscht
hier das pure Grauen das war wie eine
szeneria wie ein Drehort von einem
Tatort oder von irgendeinem
skandinavischen Krimi die halt immer
besonders brutal sind da lagen halt
wirklich fünf Personen auf der Straße
waren alle noch nicht abgedeckt in so
einer Hofeinfahrt
Wiesen viele Schusswunden auf dahinter
stand zwei Fahrzeuge die waren
regelrecht durch sieht von Kugeln es war
wirklich wie von immer von einer Mafia
Film ja damals wussten das jetzt zu
diesem frühen Moment noch nicht aber der
Verdacht kam sofort auf als eben dem
dieser Pizzeria war ja und dann stand
man da und eins habe ich wirklich nie
vergessen können das hat mich auch so
ein bisschen verfolgt einer der Toten
war noch sehr jung in der Kamera aus der
war 16 der saber gefühlt sogar noch
jünger aus und der lag auf diesem
Asphalt und man er sah eben aus als
würde er hätte sich dahin gelegt der
wäre gar nicht tot weil die so frisch
tot waren dass sie natürlich noch nicht
noch nicht die Leichenstarre und blass
waren sie auch noch nicht und während
ich dann da gestanden aber es hat lange
gedauert bis man die Leichen abgedeckt
hat
sah man dann irgendwann die Lippen
anfing weiß zu werden und das werde ich
wirklich nie vergessen das war wirklich
so das Leben endlich aus diesem Körper
und das empfand ich damals als
unglaublich schrecklich und schlimm
dieses zu sehen und er wirkte halt so
jung wie gesagt mit 16 ist man natürlich
auch noch jung ähm das fand ich damals
wirklich schrecklich muss ich wirklich
sagen was also war passiert
das vordergründige ließ sich relativ
schnell ermitteln das wer das wo und das
wann
am 14 August 2007 trafen sich der Wirt
des da Bruno Sebastiano S und sein
Lehrling Tomaso Francesco V mit vier
weiteren Verwandten des Wirts im
Restaurant um zu feiern denn der
Lehrling wurde um Mitternacht 18 man ist
und trinkt bis ca 2 Uhr dann wird der
Laden abgeschlossen und die Männer
machen sich daran mit zwei Autos
loszufahren aber vor dem Restaurant an
der Mülheimer Straße warten bewaffnete
Männer im Dunkeln und eröffnen das Feuer
auf die Festgesellschaft sie geben 54
Schüsse ab um 2:24 Uhr geht der Notruf
bei der Polizei ein 6 Minuten später ist
der erste Streifenwagen da wenig später
auch Bild man Frank Schneider solche
Fälle bei denen man so früh dabei ist
die vergisst man nicht sagt er ich
glaube das ist das ganz entscheidend
auch wirklich immer vor Ort sein wollen
und selber eben ein Bild machen wollen
und natürlich ist das emotional was ganz
anderes es zieht ein ganz anderes in
diese Geschichte rein es lässt einen
diese Geschichte auch ganz anders
erleben und eben auch dass das grausame
und schreckliche dieses Verbrechens
bekommt man ganz anders mit als wenn man
es nur auf Papier oder am Telefon
mitbekommt und auch zu sehen die ganze
auch wenn die Spurensicherung und was
mich damals auch wirklich beeindruckt
hat war das blanke entsetzt noch bei den
Polizeibeamten die machen jeden Tag
Tötungsdelikte von der Mordkommission
aber auch die war mit der Situation mehr
oder weniger überfordert der sechste Tod
ist auf dem Weg ins Krankenhaus ist der
Mann gestorben die Meldung kam er dann
eben auch noch hinterher und man hat den
wirklich angemerkt auch die war mit der
Situation erstmal völlig überfordert
auch am nächsten Tag bei der
Pressekonferenz die dann stattfand ja
und so fragen sich alle in den nächsten
Stunden und Tagen was da eigentlich
passiert ist vor dem da Bruno die
Öffentlichkeit die Kripo und natürlich
Polizeireporter Frank Schneider war das
ein Raubüberfall oder irgendeine
Beziehungstat wir hatten dann über
unsere Kontakte
nach Italien schon ausbekommen dass es
eben um einen langen schwelenden Mafia
Streit ging zwischen zwei Mafia-Familien
und die Polizei in Duisburg die
natürlich erstmal akribisch arbeitet und
den Kontakt ja nicht so direkt hat die
können da nicht in Italien anrufen die
müssen das über das Bundeskriminalamt
und Auswärtige Amt machen und hatten
noch keine Erkenntnisse und bei der
Pressekonferenz war so absurd dass
eigentlich die Polizei nichts wusste und
wir schon ganz viel und das war wirklich
eine ganz surreale Situation die Sprache
auch dann davon ja das muss man erstmal
abwarten vielleicht ist es auch ein
Eifersuchtsgeschichte wo wir alle gesagt
haben wir erschießt denn fünf Leute
wegen der Eifersuchtsgeschichte bzw
sechs ähm ja das war sehr surreal war
auch damals ist die Polizei von dieser
Situation komplett überrascht noch
überrollt wurde nachdem die Presse schon
früh Kontakte nach Italien aktiviert tut
es die Polizei auch denn natürlich
stimmt Frank Schneiders Verdacht das
Massaker von Duisburg hat seinen
Ursprung in Kalabrien
hier war eine Abrechnung unter Mafiosi
gemacht worden eine alte fede zog ihre
blutige Spur in die Gegenwart und um die
zu verstehen gehen wir jetzt mal ganz
weit zurück noch vor die Geschichte mit
den Böllern und der Schlägerei
um das Jahr 1850 tun sich Arbeitslose
Soldaten Wegelagerer und Rebellen im
süditalienischen Kalabrien zusammen sie
begehen gemeinsam Erpressungen Überfälle
und Entführungen anfänglich wird diese
kriminelle Vereinigung noch peacheria
genannt übersetzt in etwa Club junger
Burschen später setzt sich der Begriff
und drangetta durch hier ist die
Wortherkunft nicht ganz klar
möglicherweise bilden die griechischen
Wörter für Mann und heldenhaft den
Ursprung und natürlich trifft das
Gegenteil von heldenhaft so das ist von
Anfang an ein übler krimineller Haufen
Kalabrien ist arm und die Leute hassen
die Herrschenden Entfernung Rom also
bildet die in rheingitter eine
parallelherrschaft dominiert die
Lokalpolitik und die örtliche Wirtschaft
sie erpresst Schutzgelder und kassiert
für die Nutzung von Straßen oder für
Baugenehmigung später kommen
Drogenhandel und Prostitution dazu aber
weil Kalabrien so arm und unbedeutend
wirkt nimmt kaum jemand den dranketta
war ganz im Gegensatz zu den berühmten
mafia-bünden Camora und cosanosa das
ändert sich erst in den 1970er Jahren da
wird der verschwiegene Club mächtiger es
gibt in dieser Zeit aber auch eine
tödliche Krise ein Streit um Einnahmen
eskaliert und fordert von 1974 bis 1976
mehr als 230 Menschenleben das ist
tragisch und blutig aber vor allem
schadet es den Geschäft zweifamilien
erobern danach die Spitze dieser dunklen
Organisation und teilen sich die Macht
die
clansionierter und Pelle Romeo aus dem
Dorf San Luca sie sind übrigens vielfach
verschwägert und verschwitzt hat was die
Ermittlungen später manchmal ziemlich
kompliziert macht und damit sind wir
wieder beim Streit mit den Eiern und
faschingsböllern im Februar 1991
den Anfang machen angeblich junge Leute
das daran so nettas und bewerfen ein
Lokal der pelo Romeos
statt den Streit frühzeitig zu
schlichten setzen die Bosse auf
Eskalation kurz nach dem karnevalszoff
werden zwei Burschen der stranjo Seite
erschossen jetzt gibt es kein Zurück
mehr denn hinter sinnlos wirkenden
Böllern und Eiern steckt in Wahrheit ein
neuer Machtkampf der schon lange in der
Luft liegt es geht um Reviere Märkte
posten und wieder um Milliardengewinne
und so belauern sich beide Seiten immer
wieder kommt es zu Überfällen
Hinterhalten und Attentaten irgendwann
ab Mitte der 90er Jahre beruhigt sich
die Lage deutlich die italienische
Polizei geht ab dem Jahr 2000 sogar
davon aus dass die sogenannte San
luca-fede beigelegt werden konnte
offenbar haben beide Seiten erkannt dass
Drogen Prostitution und Geldwäsche mehr
bringen als Streit in diesen Jahren
erweitert den dranketta übrigens ihr
Einflussgebiet nach Deutschland aus aber
mit Friede Freude Eierkuchen ist ab 2005
schon wieder Schluss ein Mitglied des
pellevotari Clans hat sich gegenüber
einer strandjo Frau bedrohlich
aufgeführt und wird erschossen im
Gegenzug schießt der pellevotari Clan
auf einen Mann der Gegenseite und tötet
ihn und von da an wird das Gemetzel
sozusagen noch hochkarätiger denn als
nächstes schießen die strandurnierters
auf Francesco Pelle einen Boss der
Gegenseite Pelle ist fortan
querschnittsgelähmt er ordnet Rache an
und die mündet im sogenannten
Weihnachtsmarkt von 2006 der Pelle Romeo
Clan attackiert seine Gegner mitten in
San Luca dabei wird die 33-Jährige Maria
stranggo getötet
drei weitere Angehörige ihrer Familie
werden verletzt darunter ein Kind das
ist die Ausgangslage vor dem Geschehen
in Duisburg zwei Mafia-Familien haben
das Kriegsbeil ausgegraben und wieder
mal zahlreiche Gegner abgeknallt und
alle sind gespannt was als nächstes
passiert die Behörden in Italien sind
also vorgewarnt und überwachen
zahlreiche Mafiosi und deren Handys wer
jetzt die nächste Eskalation startet
muss mit seiner Verhaftung rechnen es
könnte also schlau sein den nächsten
Schachzug im Ausland zu machen
Deutschland ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
schon lange ein wichtiger Rückzugsraum
für den dranketta hier kann man sich
prima verstecken und hier kann man in
Restaurants oder im und Export Firmen
schmutziges Geld waschen auch die
blutige Feder verlagert sich jetzt hier
hin die strangers beobachten genau wer
wo ist und so dürfen sie auch gewusst
haben dass ich Marco Marmor in Duisburg
aufhielt soll der weihnachtsmörder von
2006 gewesen sein also der Mann der
Maria stanjo erschoss ihre Familie
entschließt sich im Sommer 2007 zu einer
bis dahin unvorstellbaren Maßnahme die
nächste Blutrache soll im Ausland
stattfinden in Deutschland und damit
sind wir wieder im Morgengrauen des 15
August 2007 Blaulicht blinkt über die
noch fast menschenleere Mülheimer Straße
polizisten sichern Spuren die Leichen
werden abtransportiert Bildreporter
Frank Schneider beginnt mit seinen
Recherchen in den Tagen darauf
vervollständigen Kollegen aus Italien
das Bild dass sich die deutsche Polizei
macht und auch die Ermittlungen selbst
machen Fortschritte zum Beispiel haben
Überwachungskameras im lebengebäude das
Scheinwerferlicht des täterautos gefilmt
es kann durch eine spezielle
lichtanalyse identifiziert werden
italienische Mafia Jäger Steuern viele
Erkenntnisse bei sie haben unter anderem
ein Telefonat ist ein ist Giovanni
stranggo abgehört als er die Tötung der
Mörder seiner Cousine Maria ankündigte
die deutsche Polizei kann seine DNA
schließlich nach der Tat in einem
Düsseldorfer Hotel sichern zeitweise
Arbeiten 120 Beamte in NRW an dem Fall
die Polizei braucht zwar einen langen
Atem aber der zahlt sich aus ein Jahr
nach der Tat wurde Stranges Schwager
giuseppern in Holland festgenommen also
der Mann der Ermordeten Maria stango und
im Jahr darauf schnappte die
niederländische Polizei in Amsterdam
auch den mutmaßlichen Haupttäter von
Duisburg Giovanni Sancho bei einem
Prozess im kalabrischen locali wurde er
2011 zu lebenslange Haft verurteilt und
auch in die Gegenrichtung bliebte
italienische Justiz aktiv so wurde im
Oktober 2008 der Anführer der
verfeindeten Familie Pelle Romeo
festgenommen also Francesco den seine
Gegner in den Rollstuhl geschossen
hatten
und der den Mord an Maria in Auftrag
gegeben haben soll also in diesem
blutigen Spektakel ist es ehrlich gesagt
wie eine Mafia Film es gibt ohne Ende
Verlierer und Tote und trotzdem geht es
immer weiter und so ähnlich fällt das
Fazit auch bei Bildreporter Frank
Schneider aus der mom muss sagen dass
das damals eigentlich der größte
Betriebsunfall war denn die drangeta
machen konnte die italienische Mafia aus
Kalabrien weil das hat die Polizei und
natürlich auch die Politik massiv
nachhaltig aufgescheuchtung gesagt das
kann es nicht sein so sowas können wir
hier in Deutschland nicht zulassen und
dann gab es eben die Ermittlung auch den
Austausch mit den italienischen Behörden
und schnell wurde klar wie wichtig
Deutschland für die drangehälter ist wie
wichtig auch der Weg ist die dann Götter
ist führen im Kokain Handel und das
kommt häufig vom Rotterdamer Hafen und
wird dann wirklich mehr oder weniger
nach ganz Europa verteilt und dass
Deutschland ein ganz ganz wichtiger Ort
und Deutschland ist deshalb auch so
wichtig für sie weil dort Geld gewaschen
wird die drangeta muss natürlich
wirklich Milliarden waschen das können
Sie ihn alleine in Italien nicht das
würde viel zu sehr auffallen denn dort
sind die an die Mafia jetzt hier relativ
streng und das sind sie in Deutschland
eben nicht die deutsche Politik muss man
sagen hat eigentlich immer noch nicht
wirklich erkannt wie gefährlich das ist
und das Ergebnis sieht man auch daran
das ist jetzt mittlerweile ja 15 Jahre
her und wenn man dann rückwirkend sieht
wie die Polizei damals vorgegangen ist
wie es auch aufklärungsstrukturen gab
ratzien gab Festnahmen gab hat man das
Gefühl dass es komplett wieder
eingeschlafen denn im Unterschied zu
Clans tritt die italienische Mafia ganz
bewusst nicht sichtbar auf das war
damals wie gesagt eine Art
Betriebsunfall und heute arbeiten sie
wieder im verdeckten Bereich und ich
habe vor zwei Jahren eine andere
Staatsanwälte in Italien immer treffen
können und habe den eine Woche begleitet
der unter massiven Personenschutz lebt
der wirklich keinen Schritt vor die
Haustür machen kann seine Familie nicht
das Militär bewacht sein Haus in dem
erlebt das kann man mit hier überhaupt
nicht vergleichen und er hat auch gesagt
das Problem ist dass die deutschen
Behörden ist einfach nicht wahrhaben
wollen noch die deutsche Politik nicht
er hat hier eine Rundreise gemacht hat
das allen erklärt wie verheerend das ist
auch für die italienischen an die
zubehörden dass die Deutschen nichts
machen weil wenn das Geld weiter
gewaschen werden kann und darum geht es
der Mafia es geht einfach um diese
wahnsinnigen Gewinne und die müssen halt
sauber werden dann können Sie in Italien
noch so viel machen wie sie wollen wenn
die Deutschen nicht mitziehen ist es ein
echtes Problem und stand jetzt ziehen
sie nicht mit die Tangente hat absolut
gelernt die deutschen Behörden und
insbesondere die deutsche Politik leider
Gottes überhaupt nicht und damit sind
wir am Ende der heutigen Episode
angelangt wir danken euch fürs zuhören
und freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder dabei seid und falls
Ihr Anregungen Kritik habt oder
fallvorschläge ja dann schreibt uns
gerne eine E-Mail oder schreibt uns
Nachrichten bei Instagram die Links dazu
haben wir euch natürlich auch noch in
die Show Notes gepackt die Geschichte
der Vendetta von Duisburg haben wir
erzählt mit Informationen von Bild Welt
WAZ Tagesspiegel und taz Redaktion
Stefan Hetze Wand und Frank Schneider
Postproduktion durch wild world Studios
München Schnitt die glorreiche Toni Heia
bis bald
euer Mirko und eure Toni